Speaker 1: So there is a completely perplexing
but absolutely depraved and immoral anti vaccine
campaign that is now being waged by the former
guy, by the former president, Donald Trump.
And despite taking credit for the vaccine,
despite that, it will increasingly be his
supporters who get sick and die if they refuse
to get vaccinated.
Donald Trump has now put out a statement that
is mirroring the exact anti vaccine language
of the right wing media, that Republicans
aren't getting vaccinated because they don't
trust the Biden administration politically,
even though, remember, even by their claim,
Biden had nothing to do with making the vaccine.
This is the Trump vaccine.
Now, of course, you and I know Trump didn't
really have anything to do with the vaccine
other than he agreed to have the government
pre purchase some doses, which most countries
do.
And we'll get back to that.
But let's first look at the statement that
Donald Trump put out here through his Save
America, whatever.
OK, Joe Biden kept talking about how good
of a job he's doing on the distribution of
the vaccine that was developed by Operation
Warp Speed or quite simply, the Trump administration.
So so Trump's taking credit for the vaccine
here.
He's not doing well at all.
He's way behind schedule.
And people are refusing to take the vaccine
because they don't trust his administration.
The bottom of it's just off screen.
And I apologize.
They don't trust the election results and
they certainly don't trust the fake news,
which is refusing to tell the truth.
So there are a few things here to talk about.
The first is just the unconscionable danger
of this.
For better or worse, this guy has many, many
tens of millions of ardent supporters who
are still hanging on his every word.
They are looking for any reason not to get
vaccinated.
And this is a concerted effort that we're
hearing.
Donald Trump is taking pleasure in Joe Biden
falling short of the vaccine goal that he
had set of 70 percent first dose by July 4th
or whatever the case may be.
Now, the reason that that's happening is because
Trump and people like Trump are encouraging
people not to get vaccinated.
Asked about Louisiana's low vaccination rate,
Senator Bill Cassidy, a Republican, blamed
the White House and partizan statements for
the fact that his own constituents don't trust
White House officials when they say, hey,
the vaccine is safe now.
Trump also says the vaccine is safe, but now
Trump is saying, well, you can't trust the
administration.
Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Your state of Louisiana is the
fifth lowest in vaccination rate.
Only 36 percent of people in your state have
been fully vaccinated.
You're a medical doctor.
Your thoughts about that, about the resistance
to the vaccine in Louisiana?
And is there anything you can and plan to
do about it?
A couple of things.
First, people are surprised when citizens
don't trust government.
When you have partizan comments coming out
of the White House regarding next Jim Crow
laws or people like Senator Schumer and the
White House not cooperating on a bipartisan
bill.
Oh, we are going to be partizan.
But over here, you better trust us.
That just doesn't work.
Right.
Speaker 1: So consider that when Trump says
people don't trust the administration or the
election results so they're not getting vaccinated.
And Bill Cassidy says it's partizan statements
from the White House that make people not
get vaccinated.
If this is really the Trump vaccine, Trump
says it is.
Many of his supporters say Trump did the vaccine.
Shouldn't they want to get that vaccine?
Why wouldn't you get the vaccine that Donald
Trump developed for?
You know, then Trump says, well, people won't
get vaccinated because they don't trust the
Biden administration.
Biden, as far as they believe, doesn't have
anything to do with the vaccine.
If it was Trump's, it was developed during
Trump's presidency.
It was approved by Donald Trump's FDA.
What is there not to trust?
It's the same vaccine.
Joe Biden did hire more vaccinators.
That's true.
But that makes the vaccine untrustworthy.
And also, what about every other country that
approves the same vaccines?
If there's something about Joe Biden's administration
that you don't trust, as silly as that would
be when it comes to this issue, why wouldn't
you just say, well, hold on, look at all these
health agencies from other countries that
also said it's safe, but it's all a ruse.
Trump doesn't believe any of this stuff.
Trump got the vaccine and he knows it's safe.
Trump wants to hurt Joe Biden.
And Trump is realizing if fewer people get
vaccinated, even if they die, even if their
own, they're his own supporters.
It looks bad for Joe Biden.
Thanks to Trump.
It's not going well.
And now he's using that against Biden.
That's the full story.
It's a former president weaponized his own
unvaccinated followers to try to hurt Joe.
Biden, even if they die ushe, Ron Guapa, former
FBI agent and current law professor and CNN
contributor, tweeted about this and she said
in response to my tweet about this, It's a
loyalty test.
If they support him and believe he won, they
should be willing to die for him.
Now, the side effect is that some of his followers
will die simply for choosing not to get vaccinated.
And here is Trump bragging that his own anti
vaccine campaign and that being carried out
by other fellow Republicans is working.
The effect is people will die.
I don't know that it's really going to hurt
Joe Biden.
Joe Biden, as we talked about earlier, his
approval rating uncovered is really high,
but it's going to kill off some Trump supporters
and would be Trump supporters.
Now, seriously, what would your average Trump
supporters say when told, you know, Trump
was vaccinated in January and he did it in
secret?
He didn't even admit that he was vaccinated
until March.
But publicly, even though he got the vaccine,
he's trying to discourage his followers from
getting vaccinated.
What do you think a Trump supporter would
say if you went to them and said that?
My thought is many will react by saying Trump
didn't really get vaccinated when he said
it, he was lying.
Well, but then why would he lie about that
two months later?
It's all part of some plan.
He was either forced to deep state this.
Who knows?
They will have some explanation for it.
But it is the weaponization of lack of vaccine
against Joe Biden.
But the after effect is he's going to kill
off a bunch of his own supporters